researchers at Northwestern University
have created a new material they call
hyper elastic bone it can be 3d printed
and used by surgeons to treat injuries
almost as soon as the printer finishes
once inserted this material acts as a
structural element and a scaffold for
bone regeneration in animal models it
encourages new bone cells to move in and
rebuild the injured area this means it
should help human patients regrowth
damaged or missing bone it's also
cost-effective and easy for surgeons to
customize and deploy hyperelastic bone
consists of hydroxyapatite the mineral
and bone suspended in an elastic organic
polymer it's flexible which makes it
easy to put in place but it's also
sturdy and should hold up until the real
thing grows in hyperelastic bone can be
printed at room temperature and handled
immediately it's flexible enough that
surgeons can cut it down to fit the
patient during the operation this
materials effectiveness and ease of use
set it head shoulders knees and toes
above the rest of the field
[Music]
you